what is going on everybody it is axle
beats here for anime uproar and last
week we did a video covering all of the
homunculi in both full metal alchemist
and brotherhood and since you all seem
to enjoy that so much today we're going
to be making a monster video talking
about all of the alchemists and their
specialties
if you missed that video i mean guys
what are you doing go check that one out
and if you enjoy this one and want to
see more full metal alchemist content on
this channel be sure to leave a like to
let us know if you are new to anime
uproar or you just haven't subscribed
yet make this the video that you
subscribe and be sure to click that bell
to select all notifications you can also
follow anime uploader on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar or you can
follow myself at excellionyt of course
this video will contain spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned alchemists in general are
people in the world of fullmetal
alchemist who are able to transmute the
shape or form of a mass by drawing a
transmutation circle and flowing energy
through it for example if i had a piece
of iron i could turn it into a dagger
however i could not turn it into rubber
you typically have to work with what you
have which is interesting because in the
real world alchemy was a science of
changing one material into another most
famously led into gold in fma there are
a few ways to circumvent limitations for
example seeing the gate of truth can
remove the need for a circle which will
instead see you using your body as the
circle you can also wear the circle on
some kind of clothing like mustang does
with his glove alchemy also can't be
used to produce life or a soul without a
rebound and that's really the only hard
and fast rule other than that a
philosopher's stone can always be used
to overrule any other condition with
that said there are a lot of alchemists
so let's just get into it starting with
the state alchemists state alchemists as
you might assume work for the state and
the first one we're going to talk about
is edward alright our main character he
is known as the full metal alchemist
this is because as a child he attempted
human transmutation and it rebounded
resulting in him losing his arm and leg
to compensate for this ed has an
artificial auto male arm and leg in
their place made of metal however as he
saw the gate of truth when performing
human transmutation he gained the
ability to not need a circle and can
simply clap to transmute ed's original
goal in both series is to find the
philosopher's stone to get both his and
his brother's bodies back as his name
suggests he uses a lot of metal alchemy
often making weapons like spears and
adding blades to his metal arm
while the bladed arm is his go-to in
most hand-to-hand situations he is
actually more likely to do more earth or
stone-based alchemy extending or
creating walls making spikes or pillars
etc that said this is an important time
to note that in theory any kind of
alchemist could hypothetically do any
kind of alchemy if they understood the
chemistry behind it and knew the correct
circle so ed being a little bit of a
prodigy might lean into him being able
to work with multiple elements very
fluidly as a whole though i'd think that
just about any alchemist could do any
basic transmutations of simple materials
roy mustang the flame alchemist is
seeking to raise through the ranks of
the military and create the ideal future
that he believes in from the inside
mustang is one of the most dangerous and
talented alchemists in the series as he
has access to flame alchemy something
created by berthold hawkeye berthold
became sick and he tattooed the flame
alchemy array on his daughter's back to
keep it protected after his death while
he is called the flame alchemist the
basis for this alchemy is actually to
manipulate the oxygen levels in the air
then igniting it with his spark this can
be created either through the use of a
lighter or through his gloves which have
a transmutation circle on them and are
made from ignition cloth which sparks
when he snaps
basically mustang makes a path of high
oxygen density then lights up everything
along the way once mustang sees truth
he's able to do all of this with a clap
rather than a snap or a lighter while
also granting him access to more
earth-based alchemy as well next up the
freezing alchemist isaac mcdougall after
his role in the ishvalen war he quit
being a state alchemist and committed to
destroying central similar to mustang he
wears a circle on his gauntlet and has
it tattooed on his palm his abilities
all revolve around water and more
specifically he tends to increase or
decrease its temperature if he touches
something or someone he can boil the
water within it or freeze it instantly
xiao tucker is the sewing life alchemist
who specializes in bioalchemy
specifically he creates chimeras who are
capable of speech
after creating his first talking chimera
he was unable to do so again until he
nearly lost his state alchemist ship
this led him to take some more drastic
steps so that he could create a new one
and preserve his position honestly a lot
of people seem to not like shao tucker
but at the very least i think he treats
animals like family and i think that
should count for something alex louise
armstrong is very creatively titled the
strong arm alchemist while first and
foremost being an absolute chad most of
his skills are combat focused he is a
very talented fighter and supplements
this with his alchemy while he doesn't
really have an elemental specialty he
definitely has a unique form of alchemy
by punching things he can imbue energy
into them through alchemy and launch
high-speed spikes at his enemies he can
also punch the ground to cause spikes to
sprout from it finally this probably
isn't a super relevant point but he does
tend to transmute things into images of
his own face
something which at least would take some
level of attention to detail which many
alchemists might not have an interesting
thing to note with armstrong
specifically is that he's one of very
few state alchemists who play a major
role which doesn't actually have a main
goal for himself rather he just seems to
want to do good and to help those he
cares about
tim marco is the crystal alchemist and
his original goal as a member of the
military was to create a philosopher's
stone in general he is one of the nicer
characters in the series however he
definitely struggles greatly with ptsd
from the ish fallen war
marco can't really do anything in combat
but his knowledge of philosopher's
stones also extends to destroying them
something which was hugely influential
in the fight with envy sulph jake kimley
the crimson lotus alchemist is all about
explosions this is one of the characters
who was most affected by the split from
2003 to brotherhood while in both
versions he is depicted as being
sadistic
in 2003 he is definitely much more
psychotic while in 2009 he's a bit more
philosophical
still nuts in either version though he
sees explosions as art forms making him
very similar to daedra in naruto except
again
very much more crazy he has his circles
tattooed on his palms and can
effectively clap them together to
trigger an explosion he works very
similar to mustang in all honesty as he
causes alchemic imbalances within things
to cause them to explode he can also
spread this to things that are touching
that object as well so just as mustang
can increase the oxygen and create a
path for the flame to follow kimberley
kinda does this with explosions in the
2003 version is explained that he shifts
the atomic elements within objects
turning them into what is essentially
gun powder
giolio is the silver alchemist he's a
short old dude who is absolutely battle
obsessed and savage much like kimberly
giulio has his circles tattooed on his
palms but he also has smaller tattoos on
each of his fingers this means he
doesn't have to touch hands to complete
the circle instead just closing his
hands on themselves his specialty seems
to be in making and using a wide variety
of weapons made from silver
basque grande is a
hero of the ish fallen war who was given
the name iron blood alchemist
again like most other state alchemists
he wears gauntlets with circles etched
into them as he is designed to be more
violent than most other alchemists he
slams the gauntlets together rather than
just clapping his abilities tend to
revolve around making firearms for
example turning a building in ishval
into an amalgamation of machine guns
cannons and flails
and that covers all the state alchemists
so let's get into the other major
characters who know alchemy alphonse
elrick is our second protagonist who
much like his brother was affected by a
rebound however in his case he lost his
entire body and his soul was bound with
suit of armor by his brother to keep him
around in many ways his and ed's alchemy
are very similar especially when it
comes to the more earth-based uses
however ed tends to be a bit more
creative and expressive while al is more
clean and straightforward he does like
to use traps a little bit more than ed
does though and in brotherhood we also
see him being able to transmute without
a circle as he has also seen the gate of
truth
this also happens in a different way in
2003 when he himself is turned into a
living philosopher's stone ed and al's
teacher izumi curtis has also seen the
gate of truth when she tried to revive
her dead baby losing her internal organs
in the process
fittingly much like ed and al she
specializes in manipulating her
surroundings such as walls and the
ground she can also manipulate the iron
in people's body to knock them out or
make metal weapons like ed does on top
of all of this izumi is one of the
strongest martial artists in the series
far outclassing at himself hohenheim is
ed and al's father however the dude has
been alive for about 400 years
originally he was a slave from xerxes
and hohnheim's blood was used to create
the dwarf in the flask this homunculi
taught him alchemy and eventually went
on to sacrifice all of xerxes to turn
them both into immortal philosopher
stones this essentially means he can do
just about whatever he wants for the
most part from transmuting without
equivalent exchange to healing people
his ultimate goal in the series is to
stop father and then to become mortal
both of which are achieved by the end of
brotherhood resulting in the salvation
of a mistress and him finally being able
to die hohenheim of light is his 2003
counterpart and rather than being from
xerxes or being a philosopher's stone
hohenheim is instead just a normal
alchemist who has learned how to
transfer his soul into a new younger
body this basically made him immortal to
some extent although he had to commit a
few atrocities along the way to create
philosopher's stones and make this jump
into a new body father was the dwarf in
the flask after becoming a philosopher
stone and then creating his monkey like
children again he could do just about
anything just like brotherhood's
hohenheim and then he goes on to consume
god which just amplifies this
not to mention gaining the ability to
negate alchemy in an area finally he can
also turn himself into his own gun
which not super important but look how
goofy it looks
dante is father's counterpart in 2003 as
the leader of the homunculi she was
hohenheim's ex-wife or ex-lover at the
very least and just like him she jumps
from body to body to become effectively
immortal however her soul has been
fragmented and weakened by each jump and
as such her new body starts to crumble
faster and faster each time
lyra is the final body that dante jumps
into she is a super talented alchemist
who wanted to become a state alchemist
and much like state alchemists tend to
do she uses her accessories to transmute
things specifically her necklace has a
circle inscribed on it with this she can
condense air and fire it off in
devastating bullets strong enough to
destroy buildings scar in each series is
a niche volume man who wants revenge on
the state alchemist for the horrors of
the ishvalan war to do so he breaks the
cycle of alchemy alchemy is all about
breaking things down and building them
back up in a new form using the tattooed
array on his right arm he halts the
process at the breakdown point enabling
him to destroy anything that he touches
in 2009 his left arm also has an array
on it meant for reconstruction allowing
him to perform complete alchemy in some
form in each series all of the abilities
that he gains in terms of alchemy come
from his brother's research
speaking of his brother in both series
he is a scholar the 2009 version tells
us about him knowing both alchemy and
alcohol however in 2003 this obviously
isn't the case as alka history doesn't
exist however he does perform human
transmutation in this version to try and
bring his ex-lover back to life
resulting in the creation of lust
the goldtooth doctor in brotherhood was
responsible for injecting a
philosopher's stone into king bradley to
turn him into a homunculus the doctor
seems to specialize in human
experimentation and sacrifice and can
even perform some level of human
transmutation which he uses to teleport
his would-be sacrifices fletcher and
russell tringham impersonate the lyrics
to gain resources available only to
state alchemists so that they can
complete the works of their father nash
this mostly involves creating something
called red water a liquid with alchemic
traits these ultimately accumulate in
the creation of weak philosopher stones
and birth old hawkeye as mentioned
earlier was the creator of flame alchemy
there are two homunculi other than
father that can perform alchemy
interestingly they're both the reverse
roles to king bradley as he played those
homunculi in the opposite version of
fullmetal alchemist these are pride and
wrath
2003's wrath who has edward's arm and
leg is able to use alchemy he uses this
to supplement his monkey liability which
allows him to fuse his body with
different substances
pride in brotherhood gains the abilities
of the people and objects that he
consumes this includes kimberley and the
goldtooth doctor and finally we have a
few minor alchemists that we meet along
the way often in kind of bad guy of the
week sort of roles
majal wanted to create perfect living
dolls based on his deceased love and
uses alchemy to create incomplete living
mannequins hoping that ed will teach him
how he created al's metal body majal
goes a little bit crazy along the way
especially when he learns that his love
was never really dead to begin with and
is now an old woman lujon was an
alchemic doctor that reminds 2003's lust
of her creator and she gives him a
philosopher's stone to heal his fiance
from fossil's disease however lujan ends
up falling in love with lust and
ultimately she kills him for this and
the last alchemist we have to talk about
is clara who's known as a phantom thief
she mainly uses alchemy to manipulate a
deck of cards for example turning them
into a katana and that's it every
relevant alchemist in the series as well
as the irrelevant ones as always a
question for you all which alchemist was
your favorite and if you were an
alchemist what would you specialize in i
think my favorite in the series is
probably mustang it's kind of hard to
argue with him just being insanely cool
but if i had to choose a type of alchemy
for myself i might have to choose
something similar to isaac mcdougall as
i've always had a bit of a soft spot for
water and ice based abilities if you
guys enjoyed this full metal alchemist
video and want to see more please leave
a like and if you're new to anime uproar
remember to subscribe and ring the bell
by selecting all notifications you can
help guarantee that you will not miss
any future videos and of course you can
also follow anime uproar on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar or myself at
excellionyt i want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime uproar patrons
who make videos like this one possible
special thanks to alpha sigma who is an
absolute mad lad and disciple of lord
twego himself and of course are the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans these being ingrada pate
hefa al-jatal hinokami and water the
toasted chi the spike 8227 dylan isidore
spidey life tennelle tungsten tarcus
baked buddhist and monkey d quilly and
finally thank you to all of our pro hero
tier patrons the one and only gilgamesh
the red haired raven angel cruz rathuen
de ora very gucci alicia octor bonnie
parks joanne garcia ted not ted fatboy
games corey mcgowan and soul ray slice
and dice if you enjoy our videos and
feel like they provide some kind of
value to you please consider checking
out our patreon through the link in the
description anyone who supports the
channel with even a single dollar has
access to our exclusive patreon only
discord and your name will appear at the
end of videos just like all of these
phenomenal people but for now i want to
thank you all so much for watching and
until next time remember to stay active
[Music]
you